Oi Oi pessoal tudo bem aqui é Cristiane
Cabral e ouvir conversar um pouquinho
com você sobre o poder de ir além de
crianças encontro com as palavras quando
eu comecei a me alfabetizar foi um ar de
fantasia e alegria de muitas descobertas
eu fui uma criança que gostava muito de
montar quebra-cabeça não sei como dizer
mas no momento em que eu jun tava letras
letra falava com palavra parece que eu
ia montando o outro mundo ao meu redor
e eu me lembro que durante meu processo
de alfabetização depois a gente acorda
eu aí é muito de ônibus que minha mãe
para ir ao hospital e esse até era uma
incrível momentos em que eu ali do
ônibus ia os letreiros farmácia padaria
e só você pode começa descobrindo um
monte de palavras nova límpido diferença
E como eu também tinha facinho pela
música e pelo teatro eu também gostava
de falar palavras em voz alta e foi com
uma maneira de analisar o Tom entender
para onde cada sonoridade caminhava que
emoções provocava tudo isso foi para mim
uma primeira estratégia que me colocou
muitos anos depois profissionalmente no
campo do Teatro e da literatura eu pedi
como alguém queria trabalhar com as
palavras que queria fazer das palavras
no Ofício Ofício que eu descobri muito
cedo precisava de muita disciplina na
minha casa não tínhamos muitos livros e
eu entendia que precisava ler para
conhecer mais palavras do pai sempre
dizia minha filha
quem é o pai dos burros então todo dia
com dicionário na mão você tava cobriu
uma palavra diferente o significado e
apresentar para o meu pai gostava muito
também de fazer palavras cruzadas ali a
lugar onde a gente percebi que de fato
não entendia o reino das palavras que
não podia dominar aquele universo cheio
de Campos linguísticos ser terrível
então incríveis para uma criança
descobrindo o mundo das Letras entrando
na farmácia de minha mãe aqui no armário
ficava na Cozinha desde remédio ele
descobriu o portal das palavras dentro
das carteiras de remédio as bulas quando
eu não tinha mais do que ler encontrei
nas bulas de remédios várias formas
a descobrir palavras novas e ali eu
realmente não entendia nada quanto mais
eu me sentia perdida no contexto de
palavra desconhecida mas disso ativava a
minha imaginação por isso eu ainda gosto
de ler em outras línguas de línguas
indígenas brasileiras não gosto tanto de
leite em alemão sonoridade do Alemão e
do rústico em Santa muito e fazendo
alguns exercícios de leitura e então eu
comecei a tentar se inscrever história
das minhas primeiras histórias foram
contratações no jardim da minha casa o
senhor comprou oito anos de idade E mais
uma vez no mundo das palavras me
socorrer nem que eu pude elaborar dor
trabalhar sentido da ausência essa
a saudade que nunca foi possível nomear
mas que o mundo mágico excepcional das
palavras me permitiu
o complexificar não responder deixar o
tempo passar e abraçar o meu destino
como contadora de História na
universidade de teatro na faculdade de
repente do Brasília quando eu entrei com
16 anos Nossa eu era com as meninas e
descobrir se podia entrar na biblioteca
se ter afeto ao mundo de livros a um
mundo de toras é um mundo de biografias
ao mundo de física um mundo de paz
crítica ao monte de matemática alimentou
ainda mais o meu desejo de criar de
criar história eu passava os meus dias
nas aulas nas aulas também de corpo de
dança Eu acredito muito no corpo como um
veículo que porta os verbos são
você pode palavras então eu gosto muito
de fazer atividade física oxigena o meu
corpo aquecer a minha cabeça para poder
testar e ali no Campus da Universidade
eu descobri o Centro Olímpico e as aulas
de natação uma técnica fantástica para a
escrita é nadar nadar correr fazer uma
atividade física que realmente tira
Nossa razão do tênis para depois tomar
um banho sentar e encarar uma maratona
de leituras uma maratona descrita a
faculdade eu também usei criar uma
companhia de teatro para pensar em
outros enredos dramatúrgicos em outra
festa de teatro onde as mulheres Onde os
negros aparecessem de maneira diferente
das histórias que eu havia Lido
o feliz momento mais uma vez eu tive que
é um criar o meu repertório de leitura
porque a gente não pode criar tem
considerar os paradigmas que já estão é
muito difícil é decidir no teatro só uma
cena muda o sistema Então não é
simplesmente dizer que não gostei não
estou satisfeito que não quero fazer
isso mas é para o povo a imaginação
apresentaram alternativas para esses
lugares onde a gente não se encontra no
Diabo também como espaço de
profissionalização na minha carreira
como a free eu descobri que tinha que
estar em cena com propósitos com decisão
com ousadia porque o verbo no palco ele
podia ser cortados em segundo já que o
espectador quando se tenta até assistir
embora em corpo presente caso até tu não
a grade pode sair
os escapistas voltar para casa pensando
nas contas bancárias no problema porque
a peça não arrebatou o suficiente então
eu creio no teatro como esse lugar onde
a palavra ajuda a pegar o boi na unha e
o boi é o espectador na literatura o até
durante muitos anos textos poemas
comunicação. Que eu não tinha coragem de
compartilhar com as outras pessoas eu
queria me apedreja mais queria escrever
as histórias de número às vezes buscando
finais alternativos abraçaram dicionário
a ao cantar sinônimo de e outras
palavras que pudessem colorir de maneira
mais multiplan as histórias que eu
escrevi comecei com a poesia e esse é o
lugar máximo da concentração
é o lugar máximo da fusão onde as ideias
precisam estar amalgamado e estruturas
de ritmo estruturas de condensação de
poesia usamos as palavras que são
indispensáveis os sentidos matemos
querendo provocar imagens no leitor a
poesia ela é vértice com maior
profundidade dentro dos outros gêneros
esse lugar de corte escrever é a arte de
cortar quando eu comecei a compor pontos
aí eu descobri um outro lugar o lugar da
oralidade que está na base dos nossos
saberes né eu venho de um bairro de
Subúrbio onde a gente tentava na rua
desejo calor o ver tava e quando a
Vitória Então tá amor esse meu mundo de
infância
já tá no ponto como esse ac3 do sinteps
uma única unidade de ação poucos
personagem estrutura de começo meio e
fim o clima que uma resolução Esses são
alguns dos elementos que eu procuro
sempre localizar no ponto embora suas
estruturas possam desafiar receitas
Hollywood Ana e procurar apresentar os
seus caminhos para composição ficcional
me encanta também nesse meio do Teatro e
da literatura o exercício estético de a
cara boa palavra a gente para posição
das letras do espaço no papel e o
romance é esse lugar maior de folha de
profundo para os mergulhadores para
aqueles que desejam
as contrações em capítulos que podem
Altar apresentar Vitória de uma única
personagem apresentada por outros
personagens em outros conceitos de
espaço e tempo é esse o romance que
precisa de mecanismo mais maduros de
fundantes para poder prender a atenção
do leitor no tempo de visualidades
virtualidades e tantos desafios além da
realidade fala ainda da crônica que fala
do nosso tempo atual desse relógio
kronos e que desafia apresentação por
parte do escritor de um ponto de vista
em ponto de vista um olhar sobre faço
experiências vividas no cotidiano a
crônica
o tempo rápido o tempo preciso o tempo
que vai modificando ao Largo das nossas
cidades Eu gosto muito de te ver eu
gosto muito de dirigir teatro gosto
muito de atuar Amo cantar e ler Esses
são os lugares da supremacia da criação
de caminhos de ruptura onde eu procurei
ao longo da minha trajetória conhecer a
mim mesma e por meio desse
autoconhecimento encontrar no meu
interior podemos ir além de vencer as
dificuldades de viver escrever
personalizar e atuar além das
circunstâncias além dos ditames de
plásticos pensando na riqueza da
literatura brasileira gratidão e
E aí